[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello I'm the guy welcome to the
emmanuel center here in London for this
intelligence squared debate the motion
for this debate it's time to bring
Russia in from the cold rapprochement is
in the West's best interests well Russia
under President Putin has become an
assertive interventionist power around
the world
Western sanctions followed Russia's
intervention in Ukraine and also seizure
of Crimea in 2014 in violation of
international law witness Moscow's
military intervention supporting
President Assad in Syria Russian
meddling in the u.s. political process
is now the focus of several inquiries in
Washington well that's the focus of our
intelligence squared debate we have an
excellent panel for you arguing for the
motion Vladimir Posner from Moscow one
of Russia's best-known television
presenters and analysts he was a former
advocate of the Soviet Union
and tomatillo sagramor so who is leading
expert on security in Russia at the
Department of war studies here in London
at King's College arguing against the
motion from Washington DC Michael Hayden
former director for both the CIA and the
National Security Agency and a retired
US Air Force four-star general from also
Radek Sikorski distinguished Polish
politician until recently he served as
first defence and then foreign minister
please welcome all our speakers
[Applause]
well certainly you're here from the four
panelists to for the motion and to
against our then throw open the debate
to the floor here in the Emanuel Center
and the audience you have been asked to
vote for the motion before the debate as
you are coming in then there'll be a
second vote towards the end of the
debate and you'll know how the arguments
have swung either for or against the
motion now the opening statements from
the panelists speaking first for the
motion Vladimir Posner Russian
television presenter and author raised
in Paris and New York he moved to the
Soviet Union in 1952 where he became an
advocate for the Soviet system during
the Cold War
he now hosts a popular weekly interview
show on Russian television the first
voice for the motion letting it possible
thank you I am proposed to look at the
motion we are debating from one simple
and yet fundamental viewpoint that of
national interests I would ask is it in
the interests of the West to bring
Russia in from the coat to establish
working relations in fact to establish a
web of ties involving Russia at all
possible levels or on the contrary with
this run counter to the interests of the
West well it all depends on how you
determine those interests allow me to
call your attention to the fact that
Russian society has from ancient times
been divided into two camps pro-western
and anti-western russophile the pendulum
swung back and forth and generally
speaking the anti Western forces have
been the victors supported very strongly
by the Russian Orthodox Church which was
anti Western and remains anti Western
however there was a rupture in that
fabric we're up to that lasted for
nearly 80 years I'm alluding of course
to the Baltic Revolution of 1917 which
come this fall will be celebrated in
Russia by some and Damned by others
celebrated by the anti-western Russian
nationalists and chauvinist horses and
damned by those who dream of Russia's
adhering to the values that have come to
be defined by Western civilization
during those 80 odd years all supporters
of Western values those who had
traditionally referred to as that Nicky
or Western i'ts we're purely and simply
wiped out some did escape most of the
others were killed not all some were
quiet and said what they were supposed
to say while in the privacy of their
kitchens spoken clutched voices about
the dreams that would never come true
never because no one believed that one
day things would change but change they
did and in the most incredible and
dramatic way you fell Gorbachev came to
power launched perestroika and glasses -
restructuring of the system and a
liberalisation of the media kicking off
a process that would lead to the breakup
of the Soviet Union - the true
independence of the so-called Soviet
satellites and also of all the former
Soviet republics Russians began to
travel see a world they'd been denied
this was a victory for the pro-western
forces a victory of unparalleled
magnitude and then he thought that
battle had been won and yes the battle
had been won but not the war now then
what will happen should the policy of
excluding isolating Russia continue it
will be on the question of the doubt
play into the hands of the most hawkish
and anti Western forces in Russia who
will be able to say see we told you so
we always said that America wants to
weaken us isolate us destroy us and it
will be very hard if not impossible for
those who support normal relations of
Russia with the United States to find a
plausible response to that should this
can continue here is what will happen in
Russia the number of Russians studying
abroad will be dramatically decreased
and ultimately canceled the number of
Russians allowed to travel will be
limited as it was in Soviet times
access to Western things such as movies
books and medium will be shut down the
internet will be controlled as it is in
China or for that matter to a certain
extent in Ukraine which strangely enough
does not seem to bother the West the
absolutely free and highly diverse
exchange of opinion that is typical of
Russian social media today will be
repressed freedom of speech which does
to a certain point exist today in Russia
will be curtailed Russia will close in
upon itself bring down a much less
porous Iron Curtain than before that's
becoming even less predictable this will
lead to a resumption of the hair-trigger
relationship that typifies the words of
the cold warriors and now I ask with
disc D in the national interest of the
United States I hold that it would not
and that conversely a Russia integrated
into the international community the
Russia have not just brought in from the
cold but an included not excluded Russia
is indeed in the national interest of
the United States and allow me to
conclude by saying this has nothing to
do with being pro or anti Russian it has
to do to use an expression employed in a
completely different area it has to do
with being pro-life thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
Vladimir Posner thank you very much the
first speaker for the motion now the
first speaker against the motion from
Washington Michael Hayden former
director of the CIA and also the
National Security Agency under Bill
Clinton and also under george w bush
michael aid for
good evening and let me tell you how the
light Court is for me to be anywhere of
Washington DC it's a wonderful motion
it's time to bring Russia in from the
cold and if we're voting on the last
half of it I would join Vladimir and
saying that that's a good idea because
bringing Russia in from the cold would
make it a better world it's just not
time what what even generates the
question right now for all of us what's
new what's different what what sharp
turn in in Russian policy have we
witnessed that would suggest that we
make a comparable term and and when we
bring Russia in from the cold
what are we bringing them in to and here
I would suggest it's in to a community
of like-minded like valued liked
purposed like governed nations and
Russia is not currently in that
community and it's not in that community
by choice not our choice Russian choice
what we have seen in Russia for the past
decade plus has been accelerated
corruption the corruption of democracy
of free markets of the rule of law the
growth of authoritarianism the
suppression of political competition the
end of an independent judiciary and a
serious threat to snuff out anything
resembling an independent press all of
this in a desperate attempt to justify
what is unarguably an autocracy and that
autocracy is digging deeply into the
well of Russian history to justify
itself going back to re-identify Moscow
as the third Rome as morally superior to
well you and me in a corrupt and
decadent
Russia has chosen a dark chapter of its
past
it is not chosen what could still be a
bright future and the Russia of today
has grasped on to real and perceived
historic grievances of the Russian
people and is created for its own
purposes
a view for that people of an outside
world that is relentlessly hostile
relentlessly anti-russian now the
arguments have been made that this is
fundamentally our fault that Russia has
been threatened by NATO expansion and
European Union expansion eastward toward
the Russian borders the threat to
today's Russia is not comprised of NATO
arms the threat today's Russia is
comprised of NATO ideals NATO
practically disarmed it was never an
offensive Alliance and no reasonable
military man in the Russian Federation
today can picture NATO is being poised
to threaten the Russian Federation my
army which consistently historically has
been the most powerful army within NATO
in the fifteen years between 1997 and
2012 which is the period we're talking
about here went from 20 brigades on the
continent of Europe to to hardly hardly
a posture of threat to the Russian
Federation bringing Russia in from the
cold
now this Russia really means concessions
to this Russia after all this is our
fault this is our hostile policy that
has created this serious rupture in
relations and so we're going to have to
make concessions we're going to have to
self-correct if we're going to have a
relationship with this Russia and allow
them to join us otherwise they will
continue their self-imposed isolation so
we will have to halt NATO's Baltic
deployment we should end
efforts to redress historic wrongs in
the Ukraine in Georgia and Crimea we
will be required to falsely rehabilitate
Russia as a real counterterrorism
partner to Europe and the United States
and then finally we will all have to
embrace collective amnesia for what the
Russian Federation has done for their
incredible electoral intervention into
American and European electoral
processes thank
[Applause]
[Music]
Michael Hayden thank you very much
indeed now the second voice for the
motion dommatina sacrum or sue who is a
top expert on conflict and security in
Russia and Eurasia and also on Russia's
relations with NATO and the European
Union lecturer in security and
development at the department of war
studies at King's College here in London
dommatina the floor zones
[Applause]
why why is it good to bring in Russia
from the cold because good and positive
relations with Russia are indispensable
for European security because at a time
of heightened challenges such as
terrorism brexit massive migrations
climate change we need Russia as our
partner because contrary to what many
might think Russia is a part of Europe
also because European security cannot be
built at the expense of Russia because
contrary to what is often said the West
did not single-handedly defeat Russia in
the Cold War together with the West this
Russia which was part of the USSR
brought an end to the Cold War without
shedding any blood and it was a Russia
under President Yeltsin which we threw
all its troops from Eastern Europe and
last but not least peacefully dismantled
the USSR and thereafter engaged in a
very torturous difficult road towards
democracy human rights and a market
economy with a very difficult
environment with very limited resources
and with hardly history of democracy to
look back but it showed that at allit
arianism was not in the Russian DNA and
it is not in the Russian DNA today at
the time when the USSR collapsed the
West had an option to engage with Russia
or isolate Russia we continued to
enlarge NATO which is a military
alliance very close to Russia's borders
we abandoned the ABM Treaty which is a
pillar of European and global security
we began slowly building strategic and
defence missile systems in Europe not
far from Russia's borders we went all
the way to promising NATO membership to
countries such as Ukraine with whom
Russia
very close ties both culturally in human
level on the economic level and
historically and also with Georgia which
is located along Russia's most sensitive
borders in the North Caucasus imagine
for a moment how the United States would
feel if it faced an Islamist insurgency
in Texas the enlargement of a hostile
alliance not only in Central America in
Mexico Mexico but potentially in Canada
that was a predicament that Russia faced
this is not a debate about Vladimir
Putin and his actions whether they're
right or wrong it is about what the West
can do to make sure that we address the
problems of European security jointly
what does that mean it means engaging in
a meaningful dialogue on the
architecture of Europe involving all
countries from the Urals across the
Atlantic in a dialogue that could result
in an agreement that would be binding on
all it means establishing
confidence-building measures along
NATO's bordered with Russia to help
reduce tensions and create an area where
we avoid the outbreak of an accidental
war this can be a certain possibility
ladies and gentlemen Russia has been a
positive partner to the u.s. in the war
against terrorism it has shared crucial
intelligence with the United States and
with the West on terrorist suspects it
has helped us in the war against
al-qaida in Afghanistan it is our
partner in climate change negotiations
it has worked with us on the very thorny
issue of Iranian nuclear power it has
agreed to reduce its strategic nuclear
forces when cooperation was possible it
would use many of its troops from
Kaliningrad when we decided not to
deploy our theater missile defense in
Europe it has shown good way when we
have shown good way it is very important
again that it will build a security that
include
Russia and as Defense Secretary of
Defense James Schlesinger noted any
common security order that excludes
Russia would carry with it the seeds of
its own destruction
the second remarks there for the motion
tomatillo sega rosa thank you now let's
move to the second voice against the
motion from Warsaw or Radek Sikorski
Poland's foreign minister from 2007 to
2014 and previously defense minister
from 2005 to 2007 a key architect of the
European Union's foreign and security
policy ladies and gentlemen alexa posny
[Music]
the motion says it's time to bring
Russia in from the cold rap or small is
in the West best interest let's start
with from the cold yes I think Russia is
in the goal um but is it our fault I put
to you that when the Soviet Union
collapsed we did our utmost to bring
Russia in to make Russia feel
comfortable to join our institutions we
invited Russia to join the Council of
Europe we invited Russia to join WTF
Russia and nature created a nato-russia
Council the European Union started
negotiations of a deep and comprehensive
free trade area called partnership and
cooperation agreement and it seems to be
going well despite Russia's turn towards
autocracy despite the creation of a
kleptocratic system and when did it stop
it stopped when Russia proclaimed that
she had the right to defend the
interests of Russian speakers abroad by
military force and then started doing it
first doing the answerís of Crimea then
using proxy soldiers so-called little
green men in eastern Ukraine and why
were we so alarmed by this we were so
alarmed by this because we've seen this
movie in Europe before and we don't want
to see that movie again
yeah Russia is an important country and
it is in our interest to have good
relations the military power of the
United States the economic power of the
European Union the natural resources of
Russia together we could still set
global rules but we are not together and
I put you it's not our fault when the
Soviet Union collapsed it looked like
Russia would finally decolonize itself
would finally acquire in the captive
nations becoming independent free and
democratic countries and to some extent
this is true I think Russia has given up
on Central Europe but not on the
internal Empire the the former Soviet
republics Russia has also conducted a
hybrid war not just in the former Soviet
sphere also in the West funding
extremist parties of the left and the
right funding a huge cyber operation we
felt at first some years ago for a while
Americans wouldn't believe that it could
happen to them now it has happened to
them this is not acceptable behavior and
therefore we cannot tolerate it let us
remember that this country the United
States and Russia where guarantor to
Ukraine in 1993 under the Bucharest
memorandum of the independence and
sovereignty and the enviable 'ti of
borders of Ukraine in exchange for
Ukraine allowing the third largest
nuclear arsenal to be dismantled
there are ways that Russia can bring
itself back from the cold the Crimea
issue could be to put forward a
democratic referendum the Minsk process
could be respected Russia could restore
the control over the international
border to the country that has
sovereignty over Ukraine this is a
kleptocratic regime less genocidal than
some of the previous
once these are fees not mass murderers
they kill retail not wholesale and pro
that progress course Russia is part of
Europe but so was Germany engage yes but
don't turn a blind eye when treaties are
broken or abrogated a bad thing I a BM
was probably our mistake but but INF
breach is Russia's mistake so ladies and
gentlemen yes it's in our interest to
have a working relation with an
important country such as Russia yes
Russia is in the cold and we should
bring her back but it is up to Russia
for us to be able to judge when the time
is right
thank
Radek Sikorski the second speaker
against the motion now let me ask the
those with microphones to begin moving
around please but before I come to the
audience let me tell you how you were
thinking when you came into this hall
about an hour ago
forty percent of you had not decided for
the motion thirty six percent twenty
four percent against the motion so
you've got a bit of work to do here on
my left general and former minister I
don't know which way it's going to go in
the coming period now let's get as many
voices as possible from over here hello
I grew up from I'm from Siberia Russia I
am for the for bringing Russia back from
the cold yeah all for it question yes my
question is how exactly do you think
should this bring in from the cold
heaven I mean for example Crimea I
myself is Crimean Tatar so and have many
relatives in Crimea so you mentioned
quickly that Russia should hold a
democratic referendum again but what is
crimeans once again vote to stay with
Western do you then agree with the
annexation presumably coming from
Siberia you do have a problem that
phrase coming in from the cold
Michael hey yeah very briefly as an
American I certainly understand the
concept of popular sovereignty and the
will of the people but as Radek pointed
out you know changing lines in Europe by
force even if they are passingly popular
is a very very dangerous precedent to
set and would the Russian Federation
welcome similar clever sites in Chechnya
or you Sharia and it is let the will of
the people determine whether they are or
not part of the Russian Federation I
think they take the other side of the
argument right let's keep answers short
and question short please who's at the
back I'm very the Russian people that
people but how come Western leaders
justify bringing into the cold a
government that has recently repeatedly
vetoed a UN resolution and condemned the
chemical attacks in Syria
let it be impose that I'm afraid I don't
understand the question are they things
that Russia has done wrong of course
there are there are many things that
they've done wrong the issue is is it or
is it not in the interests of the west
of the United States and of the world to
rather engage Russia than to push it
away and let things happen inside the
way they will happen that's my only
question I'm not here to defend Russia
I'm not here to defend Putin I'm asking
is it in our interest to make this
happen or is it not and my answer is yes
and there are many things that I don't
like about what's going on in Russia not
only in Russia right in Russia as well
right I'm going to take three questions
please whose by the way Russia is not
isolated we cooked in Russia all the
time that President Putin wasn't just in
Paris he comes to international meetings
he makes agreements but then she just
doesn't do what he promises not really
like as in any aggressive actions in
Russia because of what Russia has be
okay so don't say it's not being
isolated it is being pushed away out of
g7 or rather out of eh out of the
European assembly it is let's face it
let's be honest about this
this statement make up
always but the Russian Federation has
already changed borders by force they
have already used military force to
occupy other neighbors territories and
they have already interfered with other
nations elections thank you please
further back I came in undecided I think
I'm against questions for tomatillo you
said that Russia does not have it in its
DNA to be a totalitarian state I find
that extraordinary can you just expand
on that because the whole of Western
society I can't think of another state
that is more totalitarian and surely the
risk of doing this bringing them in is
old dogs new tricks and it's more like
an old wolves that's going to turn
around and bite us and is there a lady
down here no gentlemen yes I am for the
motion but my question is if Russia
accepts that their neighbors are
sovereign states how can they oppose the
self-determination of their neighbors to
join NATO if they see it's in their own
self-defense interests
thank you and the point is that there is
a framework table donatella proposes in
which Russia is a respected member it's
called the OSCE as you know Organization
for Security and Cooperation in Europe
which was ranked my agent is flagrantly
violated Russia wanted to turn the OEC
into the security architecture of Europe
and we disagreed and may I say that I
explained in my opening statement that
many efforts of many Russians to bring
down the most totalitarian system that
had existed in the USSR so to argue that
Russians are genetically totalitarian
good Russians are not in power in Russia
they were in color
I'd like to make a point here the idea
that some nation is genetically somehow
not up to par to me smells as fascism
I'd be very careful
[Applause]
if Russia defines acceptable security as
controlling the behavior of its near
neighbours in terms of what its near
neighbors consider to be it's got their
government their policies and their
relationships that simply can't stand
right let me get some more there are an
enormous number of hands be patient
there's a voice there with a microphone
what are you for against the motion
where you from I'm from Georgia for the
moment I'm again and I have the question
like we hear talked quite a lot about
the fears of Russia but what about us we
have fears also Georgians Ukrainians
that's the question and like if you will
have positive agenda positive agenda
nobody will run far from Russia be
democratical economically attractive
that's the solution let let me put that
you immediately
I don't Ella particularly because part
of Georgia is still held ecology by
Russian forces because security is
indivisible you cannot build your
security at the expense of someone
else's insecurity and Georgia borders
the most sensitive border of Russia
which is the North Caucasus and is
facing a very vibrant Islamist
insurgency I am NOT arguing in favor of
Russia's occupation of Georgia and
making it very clear that there are
conditions that must be set in our
dialogue with Russia
I'm just arguing that we need to build
an inclusive security system in Europe
this country last I look has 250 tanks
France 250 tanks Germany 250 tanks
Russia 5000 so so don't tell me that we
are about to invade Russia nobody
you know nobody has said that you're
about to invade Russia and it's not
about tans ladies and gentlemen it's
about missiles and it's mainly American
methods the top polish missiles for
technical or Romanian heavens you now
have your own American president don't
you tell me what to do George please at
the back my closet panel is the threat
of Russia massively exaggerated by the
EU by military by the military in the
West by NATO sustain its position as I
understand it the Russian economy is
more than Italy their defense
expenditure is Nestle United Kingdom so
is that really a military threat down
here the lady please can you explain why
there is no freedom of speech or
expression in the in the in Russia and I
think this could be the stumbling from
right thank you Pisa factories I know
I'm called emotion people keep saying
that Rustler are meddling in the
elections but actually the CIA see could
be sent money across after the Second
World War to fund a European movement
so that's meddling with things thank you
now as a former head of the CIA and the
NSA can I just pick up that point over
there given what's being what's
happening in Congress at the moment in
the US does the CIA meddle in political
processes anywhere in the world there is
a there is a history
you know you're not in office at the
moment there is an acknowledged history
of my agency trying to level the playing
field in Europe after World War two with
last communist movements that let me
offer the view that the color
revolutions and what happened in the
Maidan in Kiev were spontaneous
combustion they were not engineered by
Western intelligence services that my
poster there was a question there about
freedom of speech Yura you have your own
television program you feel constrained
as a television presenter are there are
there mind walls which means that you
can't do certain things as a senior
commentator and analyst in Russia there
are dirty trillion things that channel
one which buys my show will not accept
and I know this so you didn't have
freedom of speech I've been around the
block a couple of times I am known to be
not a supporter of Putin in Russia I
work my shows on channel one which is
controlled by the government and I can
pretty much say what I want with some
limitations there are anti-putin
newspapers anti-putin radio shows before
you say that there is no freedom of
speech in Russia go there listen talk to
people it's not the kind of freedom of
speech I would like to see it's much
less but to say that it doesn't exist
this is not China believe me it's a very
different country now they think that
[Applause]
even even in communist Poland we had
freedom of speech what we had trouble
with was freedom after the speech
[Applause]
but I have to get back to that other
point up there about exaggeration of the
military threat yeah well the Soviet
tonight I actually meant Soviets all
right it's not a senior moment the
Soviets were famous for what they called
the correlation of forces and it is an
approach to war fighting that the
russian armed forces have inherited it
is a very scientific very fact-based
approach to who holds military advantage
there is no conceivable way that Russian
officers schooled in that methodology
could view the current NATO deployment
and frankly the entire NATO military
infrastructure as representing any kind
of serious threat to the defence of the
Russian Federation let me get two more
questions please let me just remind you
that Russia lost 27 million people as a
result of that and you say nothing to
fear every Russian remembers what that
was about
let me go to formal hooks microphone
okay I promise you cannot justify policy
based upon the mythology of the past
together the definite real is the devil
feel that there is no equivalence
between that Soviet nightmare and the
reality we have in Europe to date and if
you allow them to justify today's policy
based upon that history they're never
coming in general it is not and also
there were no problems there were
the Soviet Union many of whom you killed
in your own gulag join the war anybody
you know not yes I might at the end of
this show but anyway
Vladimir I have to get you to the end of
the show so let's just has to water
people up there I'm for the motion Bank
questions for those who are debating
again what positive purpose do you think
keeping Russia in the cold at the moment
says because we seem to have sanctions
in a certain amount of the g8 and it as
far as I can tell is making things worse
it's led to things we talked about in
Crimea and Ukraine it just used it
inflamed conflict and that suggests what
Vladimir saying earlier is right all
right 30 seconds each please there
please
I think the people hostile to the motion
are being a little bit Precious about
some of the criteria they're setting up
if you were a country on the border of
Russia you're just going to have to lump
it my question is if we did take steps
to let people in from the cold
with the two people who are proposing
the motion tell us how they think Russia
would react what positive things might
happen if we did do the various things
we ought to do all right
what engage Russia would do thank you
right these got the microphone here I am
from Ukraine we do not have any
limitation of freedom of speech most
certainly if you say that Russia has no
limitation of freedom of speech then as
for today and the issue of state whether
Russia should be brought in from the
cold does Russia want to be brought in
from the cold if you are so scared of
the West then maybe invest to deal with
the sphere at first to seek assistance
for it through your own means but not to
act upon it thank you please cause we
actually in a way missing the whole
point
I Russians are very easy to enemy to
have lots of missiles lots of times lots
of soldiers and their little red
telephone on a desk in each ends of the
Advanta which would be focused on Islam
Russia is supporting the pantograph this
movement
by countries and respond Russian and
they're the ones blowing people off on
the streets of London right thank you
first of all that point to both of you
who are against the motion that you're
being rather precious oh you feel
pressures I don't know about that but
the point is that the Bucharest NATO
summit we did not offer either Georgia
or Ukraine a membership action plan and
President Putin nevertheless did what he
threatens to do which is to take
Georgian territory and then take
Ukrainian territory free frame which is
essentially what we have between the
European Union and Ukraine without any
promise of membership does not threaten
anybody it was Russia that moved the
goalposts because Russia now wants to
create an alternative pole of
integration with herself
Abbott Lee we the Europeans should be
disintegrated Russia can augment its
strength all right inmate event but it
is it is a different conception from
what Russia had managed to do so thank
you for the I'll be very brief we talked
about how do you how do you do this how
do you approach if you were going to
approach the Russians how do you get to
a better place
I can I can give you the historical
account of two successive American
administrations whose Russian reset
policy is a mass pile of rubble we've
had two administrations expending
tremendous domestic political capital to
reset American relationships with the
Russian Federation and they both ended
in disaster when the Russian army
crossed what the rest of us thought was
an international border all right please
down here the lady here
hello I'm for demotion and the
historical precedent has been exercised
here when that successful alliance has
been brought between Churchill and
Stalin the extreme circumstances
so my question is are the extreme
circumstances today not enough with the
terrorism thank you motion I'm Donna -
it says we need to ask ourselves how we
got to where we are and I agree
introspection is always a good thing
I've seen no sign of that coming out of
Moscow where where are the people saying
why are all our neighbors moving away
from us or why they desperately moving
away for us even belorus it messiahs are
concerned it's not that NATO's going up
to the Russian border they're trying to
get away from you
they're moving westward I think that
this is not entirely true
I think there has been a lot of effort
by many of these countries and peoples
and companies within these countries to
develop close economic ties with Russia
you find that in Belarus in Ukraine in
Kazakhstan this is not true and what is
also important to note and this is what
we are standing for we are not giving
Russia a blank check we are talking
about engaging in a dialogue that
reduces tensions so that we can address
key issues of security in Europe and
globally together and there are many
instances contrary to what was said on
the other side of the aisle where Russia
and the United States have worked
corporately and Vladimir Putin in the
early 2000s offered help towards the
West in its war against terrorism thank
you the lady there peace how is Russia
pursued now as a old proven enemy or is
it kept characteristic villain what is
the balance let me ask you that there
Michael Hayden and Radek Sikorski on
that issue of the character to the
characterization I should say yeah I'll
try to be very efficient here because
that's a very important question I was
director of CIA for three years the last
three years of the Bush administration
and I will admit a failing that I didn't
pay enough attention to Russia at that
time contrary to the Russian expectation
the Russian folklore that I was spending
every waking moment making life worse
for bella' Vladimir Putin the current
vision we have of the
Federation is a very precarious leader
despite the opinion Bowles who is trying
to look for legitimacy for what is
fundamentally a very difficult political
domestic situation term one Putin one
I'm going to be autocratic but don't
worry I'm going to make you rich oil is
over one hundred and ten dollars a
barrel now oil is floating is less than
half that price and Putin as a means of
self justification is I'm going to be
autocratic but don't worry about it I'm
going to make you proud because these
people are real dangers and I'm going to
defend you against them I do think the
engine behind an awful lot of Russian
activity that we view to be dangerous is
a domestic political engine for domestic
survival for the president thank you
right when george w bush first met
Vladimir Putin the words that he
subsequently regretted he claimed to
have looked into his eyes and got a
measure of his soul what do you think
Donald Trump will see when he looks into
like recruiting guys probably in July
when they meet at the g20 and what
conclusions do you think he will draw
Michael Hayden I had to ask you did you
examine Vladimir Putin's eyes
you know I'm not not not personally let
me give you another American experience
along those lines this is Bob gates
former DCI before he became Secretary of
Defense so I actually was in Bob's
office he then came back and reported to
do President Bush I looked mr. Putin in
the eye and I saw the KGB that is very
revealing we have a man whose world view
was shaped my service in an intelligence
service with an incredibly
conspiratorial view of the world
that's an incredible argument earlier
thank you thank you very much
wait wait a minute predicate this is a
man who on 9/11 called the United States
offered Hayes and offered a helping hand
and offered the desire of Russia to
become member of NATO this was a man who
understood what the real challenges were
it is not the threat of Russia that we
are facing it is a threat of Islamic
radical jihadism if terrorism the kind
of extreme circumstance in which we have
to essentially forget about other
countries internal arrangements and make
alliances with them anyway up with
respect because I know what just
happened in London I was actually a
white eyewitness the previous attack on
on Westminster Bridge terrorism is not
an existential threat to our way of life
it's nasty but it cannot bring it down
right I now have the debate result and
let me remind you that when you came in
here 40 percent of you did not have any
idea which way you wanted a vote 24
percent were on that side of the house
against the motion and 36 percent were
on that side of the house now listen
click carefully and precisely to what
I'm about to tell you five percent are
undecided now so you all shifted almost
all of you against forty seven percent
for forty eight percent
[Applause]
[Music]
so the those speaking against the motion
have persuaded more of you to swing
dramatically but ultimately the floor
was won by the proposers for the motion
that it's time to bring Russia in from
the cold can I thank you all very much
indeed the speakers all of you and from
Enoch gowing here in the emmanuel center
on behalf of the BBC and intelligence
we're thank you very much indeed
and congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]